visit booktv.org you can also follow
along behind the scenes on social media
at book tv on twitter instagram and
facebook
good evening everyone good evening
good evening welcome to politics and
pros my name is travis cohen i am an
events uh event so here and a book
seller as well and i also uh run the
sign first editions club
i'm just going to do some quick
housekeeping and then we'll just jump
right in
i might just want to take a second to
remind everyone to please um silence
your cell phones uh we will be uh
recording audio and video for tonight's
event um such a great incentive to
silence those phones and then also
to ask us the same questions when we
open the floor up to questioning which
there's a standing mic right here
in the middle for when we do that
after um
after david's talk
um following the talk and the questions
there will be a signing we have books
available behind the register
so after the talk if you want to get up
and purchase the book then come back
dave will be more than happy to sign
them and then finally after
after everything said and done if you
could just uh collapse your chairs and
just prop it up against a surface that
would be greatly appreciated by the
event staff thank you
uh yeah
so yeah tonight uh politics bros has the
pleasure of hosting uh david enrich uh
finance editor at the new york times uh
he is pre he previously was a reporter
and editor at the wall street journal in
new york and london
before that he was the journal's
european banking editor based in london
and a journal reporter in new york he
has won numerous journalism awards
including the 2016 gerald loeb award for
feature writing he is previous
previously the author of the spyder
network how a math genius and gang of
scheming bankers pulled off one of the
greatest scams in history which was
shortlisted for the financial times best
book of the year
um in his trenches trenchant new book
dark towers deutsche bank uh donald
trump and the epic trail of an epic
trail of destruction uh david traces the
bank's dark history uh its relationship
with the u.s president as well as the
tragic case of um william brooksmith to
illustrate the evolution and character
of an entity that's become a global face
of the global face of financial
malfeasance i'll just let him jump in
everyone please join me welcoming david
entrance to uh
hello
well
i have uh
had the pleasure of doing lots of book
events over the past few years from my
previous book and i've done book events
like this with i'm not kidding six
people in the room
and it so this is just awesome and i'm
gonna take out my phone and just take a
picture because
my wife my wife will not believe this
and
so maybe i'll take a couple pictures
just
uh
so thank you all for coming it's really
it's an honor to be here uh and it's
extremely gratifying to see a turnout
like this um
for a book about a european bank that no
one's ever heard of um
so i just wanted to i i guess for
fiction or non-fiction audiences and
non-fiction books people generally do
not read to start but i want to read
just the opening section of the book
which will just take a couple minutes
just to set the st set the scene
and then i will
explain why i'm setting the scene and
how i got into writing this book in the
first place
it was a little before 1 pm when a wiry
american emerged from the tube station
into a drizzle the type of dreary
january weather that earns london its
reputation as a depressing place during
the long winter months
the man looked around sloane square
normally even in this dark season the
block was pretty and bustling with
shoppers
this sunday in early 2014 it was
desolate
val brooksmith didn't feel well
he had woken up groggy from the previous
night's drug fueled jam session with his
band
then on the crowded underground train on
his way to chelsea he had been jolted by
a surge of negative energy like a dark
spirit had brushed past him
he lit a cigarette and trudged toward
the entrance to the saatchi gallery his
head down and a futile attempt to stay
dry
he was scheduled to have brunch at the
gallery's cafe with his parents
the last time he'd seen them was a month
earlier in december 2013 before they'd
set off for the caribbean and then a
vacation in oman val had just turned 38.
while he was a talented musician with 34
albums to his name none of us were
chart-toppers he lived off the largess
of his father bill who had spent many
years as a senior executive at deutsche
bank one of the world's largest
financial institutions
tall skinny scraggly his friend
sometimes told him he resembled a [ __ ]
val was determined on this sunday not to
get an earful from his mother about
looking like a slob
he wore slacks a blue blazer and a black
woolen cap
at exactly one o'clock val arrived at
the arched brick wall that snaked around
the saty gallery
he was notorious in his family for never
being on time but here he was and his
obsessively punctual parents were
nowhere to be seen
where are you guys he texted his mother
allah she didn't respond
val wandered across the pedestrianized
street perusing a row of boutiques and
overpriced shops
he came across the tashan bookstore
which specialized in coffee tables about
art
or coffee table books about art and
culture
for the past couple of years val had
been collecting rare first editions the
older and more famous the author the
better
he was so into his hobby that he had
done volunteer work for an organization
that gathered unwanted books from estate
sales and distributed them to needy
children
val would sift through the stacks
searching for hidden gems and pilfer
them for his own little library
the bookstore is mostly empty
unlike this
val browsed its shelves until something
caught his eye
an enormous volume with a shimmering
silver cover priced at 650 pounds about
a thousand dollars
it was a limited edition collection of
harry benson's iconic photos of the
beatles including the one of a pillow
fight in a paris hotel room
the book was signed by the photographer
and its pages were so luxuriously
metallic that val could see his
reflection in them
he started to daydream about convincing
his parents to buy it for him is a
belated birthday gift
val's iphone buzzed interrupting his
reverie
the call was from a blocked number val
answered it a woman with a thick accent
val was pretty sure is his parents
housekeeper bell was on the line
emergency emergency she shouted your
father your father
val asked what she was talking about he
couldn't get a coherent answer the only
thing he could think was that he needed
to get to his parents flat which is
about a mile away in the posh kensington
neighborhood
he put the beatles book down raced
outside and hailed a black cab
21 evelyn gardens he instructed the
driver
the 10-minute drive felt endless the cab
seemed to crawl through london's traffic
choke streets past stately townhouses
and brick apartment blocks and high-end
restaurants and organic grocery stores
bundled locals hurried along the
rain-slicked sidewalks nearly keeping
pace with the taxi
val went through the possible scenes he
might encounter when he arrived
maybe his father was hurt
maybe there was a big family argument
or maybe it was just the bill was locked
out of his computer and needed his tech
savvy son's help
the taxi pulled onto evelyn gardens a
wide quiet street that instead of having
a median allowed cars to park in the
middle as well as on the sides
now in addition to the bmws and audi's
and mopeds an ambulance was stationed at
the curb
val paid the cabbie and sprinted across
the street
his parents lived in a flat on the third
floor of a white trimmed red brick
building
its heavy black door normally opened via
buzzer was a jar
val galloped up two flights of stairs
the door to his parent apartment was
wide open
in the middle of the hallway bill
brooksmit was lying on his back his eyes
closed
a neck brace tilted his head back at an
unnatural angle
a paramedic's plastic tube jutted from
his mouth
val's mother was curled in the fetal
position on the dark wooden floor her
head resting on a pillow next to her
husband's face
she was wailing
belle kneeled beside her stroking her
hair
what the f is this val screamed
he killed himself his mother gasped he
hung himself with daisy's leash
so
um
that's obviously an upsetting way to
start this talk and an exciting way to
start the book uh
nine days this was january 26 2014
and nine days after that i lived in
london at the time and was a journalist
working for the wall street journal
and i got in touch with val
because i'd heard about bill brooks with
suicide he was a very senior executive
at deutsche bank
and i want to learn more there were
rumors flying all over london that broke
smith had committed suicide in part
because of
he because he was upset about stuff that
had been going on at the bank he was
extremely close to the bank's ceo at the
time a man named anshu jain
and i wanted to figure out what was
going on and
uh bill and his wife allah had three
children val is actually his stepson and
so i divvied up the task of contacting
his widow and his family members with a
couple of my colleagues and i got val
and val had a very active social media
presence at the time he was in a band
and called bikini robot army and the
band uh was active on twitter and
instagram and facebook
and and val was a character i could tell
right away i mean he was posting lots of
pictures about doing wild and crazy
stuff lots of drugs
lots of kind of vaguely pornographic
pictures of his exploits with women and
it was he was just kind of this
completely inappropriate guy
and
on his website there was an email
address and i emailed him and introduced
myself and said you know i'm looking
into your father's death and i'm trying
to understand more about what happened
and why and i'm hoping we can talk
and you know i've been a journalist at
that point for i don't know like 14
years or so and i've written lots of
emails of that nature made lots of phone
calls of that nature
and i've been conditioned like like
every other journalist you almost never
get a response in that situation and
it's usually a situation where you maybe
send that initial email and you want to
be respectful because there's a tragedy
and obviously the family is grieving but
you also need to be persistent and so
that was kind of my opening salvo and i
expected over the coming days and weeks
i would be making additional phone calls
sending more emails maybe showing up at
his home
and lo and behold the next day val
responded to me and he said what is it
you want to know about my father and i
explained that i'd heard rumors about
what happened with his dad
and val
grudgingly agreed to get on the phone
with me a few days later on the
condition that my colleagues and i
stopped harassing the rest of his family
which seemed fair enough
and
so a few days later i got on the phone
with val and this started a journey that
has led
to this book um because val it turned
out had gotten on to his dad's computer
very shortly after his death
and had figured out the passwords to his
uh personal email addresses or his
personal email accounts his yahoo and
gmail accounts and inside of those
accounts he would eventually find
his father had been sending and
receiving
thousands and thousands of emails and
documents related to his work at the
bank and it val eventually turned them
all over to me
and it what it showed bill brooks it
turned out i started then doing a lot of
research into who bill brooksman was
and he be he becomes he and val become
kind of the protagonists i guess you
would say
of this book and bill broke smith was
he's american
he was a minister's son in the illinois
kind of in rural illinois
he became a banker but he was kind of
not your normal
reckless aggressive testosterone banker
he was much more cerebral thoughtful and
intellectual he was quite conservative
and he became known but at first at
merrill lynch where he really got a
start in the banking world and then at
deutsche bank
as the man with the ethical compass kind
of the conscience of the place and he
was the guy
who you know this is an industry
dominated by uh id you know there's
everyone wants a go go go step on the
gas
uh you know shoot first ask questions
later bill was kind of the super ego in
that in most of these scenarios where he
would say wait a second this looks a
little too easy to actually be right
shouldn't we ask some more questions and
he was smart enough
and respected enough that people
listened to him and so what happened at
deutsche bank over the years is a it's
kind of a parable for what happened
in the banking industry writ large over
a long period of time
banks went from being
these companies that essentially existed
to serve their customers
and they became entities that
not only their customers actually their
customers it was the communities in
which they operated it was their
employees it was governments
and of course it was their shareholders
the investors their owners and they went
from kind of serving a whole wide range
of constituencies like that to serving
just one very narrow constituency which
was their shareholders and that meant
that meant that their goal went from
doing what's best for clients and
communities to doing what's best for
shareholders and that meant maximizing
profits as quickly as possible and so i
got to know bill brooks through talking
to his friends and family members and
former colleagues and then got to know
him through reading his emails and
seeing him in action trying to curtail
people's risk-taking and try and
remember this fundamental question of is
this best for clients and if not why on
earth are we doing it this it really was
kind of quaint and old-fashioned
and i kept thinking about this and we
didn't really write very much about this
at the time because this is 2014
2015 and it's interesting and deutsche
bank was a really important financial
institution and a really troubled
financial institution at the time but
you know i was working for an american
newspaper and this is a german bank a
european bank that despite its grave
problems and despite its big presence in
the united states no one really cared
and then in 2016
a certain someone started running for
president and that certain someone
had a very very special relationship
with deutsche bank
donald trump was completely off limits
to the mainstream financial world
because he had this nasty tendency of
defaulting on virtually every loan he
received for a very long period of time
and that's not you know when banks are
looking for customers to do business
with someone who has a
well-documented pattern of stiffing his
lenders is generally not your first
point of call
and it so he was just off limits banks
would not touch him they wouldn't return
his phone calls i heard some crazy
stories about the great lengths that
banks would go to avoid doing business
with donald trump even his friends
wouldn't touch him and there's this one
anecdote that i love telling people
about uh because you can just kind of
see it based on what we know about trump
these days and
so the story goes like this it's at bear
stearns which was i don't know if anyone
remembers bear stearns it used to be a
wall street bank and then it collapsed
uh because it wasn't a very well-run
wall street bank so
and even bear stearns wouldn't touch
donald trump bear stearns knew
uh the guy who's one of the top
executives there a guy named ace
greenberg and
he used his relationship with ace
greenberg to kind of get his foot in the
door
and proposed that bear stearns lend him
i think it was 100 million dollars and
ace greenberg told one of the bankers
there okay go deal with donald trump he
wants a hundred million dollars and the
banker talks to donald trump it's not a
crazy pitch that trump's making but it's
trump so they're not gonna lend him
anything and
uh he says okay donald i'll call you
back when we made a decision and he just
decides he's not gonna call him back and
trump is probably smart enough to get
the message that
the lack of return phone call means no
thank you we will not be loaning you 100
million dollars
trump didn't get the message and capcom
the guy back over and over again and the
banker just didn't know how to say no
and so just wouldn't and return his
phone calls
trump took ace greenberg this guy's boss
probably his boss's boss out to
breakfast one day and says ace
why can't i get my phone calls returned
it's so rude and it ace comes stomping
back in after breakfast and says the
banker why are you not returning his
phone calls that's so rude and the
banker says well we can solve this
problem by lending him a hundred million
dollars otherwise i don't know what you
want me to do and a says well we're
obviously not doing that so but figure
out a way to solve this problem and so
the banker
thinks about it for a little bit
and finally decides he's got a plan so
he calls back donald trump
and he says donald i'm so sorry i've
been dodging her phone calls is really
rude but i've got to say we can't make
this loan and trump says why can't you
and he says well ace greenberg doesn't
want to and trump says no it gets better
trust me and ace greenberg says or trump
says what are you talking about ace and
i are buddies in fact just this morning
i had breakfast with him and the banker
says yes donald and that's just the
problem ace came back and said there are
four people we can't do business with or
we don't want to be on the other side of
a loan from henry kravis bill gates
warren buffett and donald trump
and trump pauses for a second and thinks
about it and says
yeah i can see that that makes sense and
and i heard that story and i just
thought to myself
i sometimes discount the uh the value
that investment bankers provide and the
solutions that they cook up and i had to
say this gave me a whole new
appreciation for the for the cleverness
of some investment bankers uh
anyway deutsche bank did not have the
scruples that bear stearns had when it
came to deciding whom to lend to and it
was so eager for to develop a foothold
in america and develop a presence on
wall street that it needed to kind of
pick up the scraps that other banks
wouldn't touch and
donald trump was one of those scraps and
so starting the late 1990s
uh the bank made started making what
would turn out to be about two billion
dollars in loans to trump over the next
20 years
and it was by the time trump was elected
president
he still owed three about 350 million
dollars deutsche bank was by far his
largest creditor they were the
they had financed all of his marquee
projects including here in washington uh
what used to be the old post office
building and is now
the trump something hotel uh
and it so
i started looking back at this
relationship i developed with val
brooksmit everything i'd learned about
his son or everything i'd learned about
his father and his father's career and
kind of being a voice for probity and
conservatism and risk management inside
this reckless out-of-control bank
and i realized that maybe this was the
vehicle to tell the story of how this
random
obscure german bank with a funny name
that no one can pronounce no one in
america has heard of how it became not
only synonymous with financial
destruction and economic doom and mayhem
but also really helped propel donald
trump to the white house
and it so i've spent the past two years
or so
reporting and writing about this for the
new york times it primarily focused on
the trump relationship because i already
kind of knew the deutsche bank story
and it has just been
i'm a nerd and i had spent a lot of time
probably the past 10 years focusing on
and obsessing about deutsche bank and
wondering why no one would pay attention
none of my my editors kind of rolled
their eyes when i started talking about
it and so it's just been such a pleasure
to actually have a way to tell this
story now in a way that
amazingly
people seem to care so uh
that's my thing
and i would be happy to answer questions
i'm sure people have loved questions
about trump and
i have lots of answers so
[Applause]
and i was told to make sure people use
microphones
okay
uh sir
uh given your
research on the origins and history of
deutsche bank
is it your view
that
the bank's
financing of auschwitz
which i assume included its crematoriums
was that did they know of what they were
doing
yes
well
it's not quite that simple but first of
all their work supporting the nazis is
much more extensive than just finance in
the construction of auschwitz which they
did they also financed the construction
right next door to auschwitz
uh to a chemical factory that supplied
the poison gas
yeah
you guys know this uh it
deutsche bank was the company
that conducted many of what were known
as aryanizations of
jewish-owned businesses all over europe
uh as germany conquered those countries
it took over the local banks and stopped
lending and kind of helped get jews out
of the companies and off their customer
ranks
it took the gold that uh
the nazis had taken out of the teeth and
out of the jewelry boxes of jews and
others and sold it to provide the nazis
with hard currency
um
so this is this is in fairness to the
bank which sounds ridiculous given what
it just said uh this is what large
german companies were doing in order to
survive at the time and so deutsche bank
is not unique in having done something
evil
uh
it is clearly a party to genocide and i
think there it's been easy for the bank
with the benefit of many decades having
passed to kind of sanitize that basic
fact and explain it away
the reality is that there's no we don't
know for a fact that deutsche bank knew
exactly what was happening inside
auschwitz or what that gas was going to
be used for or whose gold it was that
they were selling in istanbul uh i think
we can kind of apply a
just reasonable standard to this looking
back and how could they not have known
come on there is
the the one of the board members of the
chemical company that was making the
poison gas was the basically the ceo of
deutsche bank so if he didn't know
i mean how could he not have known
there's but i don't have proof of it uh
but i
am i think it's safe to operate under
the assumption that deutsche bank knew
about this
and did it anyway and i think it's
dangerous to make too many historical
comparisons to something that is really
incomparable in human history
but it is true that deutsche bank over
and over again in its 150 year history
this is its 150th birthday by the way
happy birthday deutsche bank uh
uh over and over again they have done
the expedient thing in order to and
taken shortcuts in order to increase
profits and sometimes to survive
and that has led them
to commit
many many crimes obviously partaking in
genocide is stands out as i think
uniquely evil but they've done a lot of
bad stuff and it generally is because
they are as much money as possible as
quickly as possible consequences be
damned wow
okay thank you
you're welcome
that's probably more than you were
looking for
hey first of all thank you for writing
this book i work in i'm a financial
regulator and i think somebody's been
needing to tell the story of db for far
too long so thank you for you're welcome
for putting where are you at regulator
uh federal reserve um i'd like to ask
you a question about um i'm sure you're
aware that val
i can't pronounce his last name so i'm
not going to try to
i'm sure you're
i'm sure you're aware that val
um
he's very active on social media saying
that you're not accurately portraying
his version of events
his theory or what he's saying is
generally that it's much more direct the
connections between
russian money laundering through
deutsche bank
um to pay off trump is the nuts and
bolts of it yep i haven't finished your
books i don't know if you go that deep
into it but he's pretty adamant that you
do not touch on that yeah at least to
the extent that he wishes that you did i
was just hoping if you could comment on
that yeah i was actually hoping someone
would bring this up because
i'm gonna i'm going to answer your
question i promise you but i think let
me just step back a little bit first
so val and i go back about six years and
he
one of the things i'm good at as a
journalist it turns out i'm really good
at working with sources and i'm good at
getting people who aren't supposed to
talk to talk and that's i'm not very
good at a lot of things but that's one
of the things i am good at and so i've
had a lot of relationships with
complicated sources over my career as a
journalist and val
far and away
no
close competitors is the hardest most
complicated most intense source
relationship i've ever had and that's
partly because i've known him for so
long it's partly because i've known him
in the context of him having suffered
this awful tragedy
uh which is his father's death and it's
also partly because val is a complicated
person this is someone who
was shoved into the foster care system
at a very young age and was basically
left there by his family even though
they were there and could have taken
care of him and he was left there in his
from ages five to nine so his formative
years it's someone who subsequent to
that has had a lot of problems with
substance abuse and addiction
and it and those are issues that he
continues to deal with
and it so this is a he is a troubled
complicated person whom i care about and
whom i have a tremendous amount of
respect for and sympathy for uh
val and i are like not getting along
that well right now and we're not and
i'll be honest about that uh and that's
frankly kind of an understatement uh
back in october i wrote a story about
val for the new york times that was kind
of described the very complicated very
intense relationship that i just alluded
to
and in that i mentioned the fact that
val had a history of uh substance abuse
he had a history of credit card theft
and i noted that one of the things that
was motivating val as he tried to share
his father's secret documents uh with
media including myself over the years
was that he really wanted to make a name
for himself he wanted to become kind of
famous he was trying to get a film deal
and i was actually just out now val
lives in l.a now and i was just out
there visiting him last week for a
podcast we're doing and what i told him
then is that i actually regret
what i wrote how that's kind of the tone
that i took at points in that article i
think it was
it was kind of it was accurate and i
think honest from my perspective it was
written in the first person but it was a
little too hard and it was a little too
mean
and i told him i'm sorry and i am uh
so i say that all not to like just have
you guys be my therapist but because i
think this provides context as to why
val's so angry and so val after that
article ran which is i think early
october has been on he's been kind of
waging a war against me online which is
very tricky for me to deal with and
completely uncharted territory and one
of the things he's been doing is talking
to some other news outlets that are
uh
and i say this with respect but that are
not the new york times or the washington
post or the wall street journal or
bloomberg or reuters or the associated
press or the financial times or cnn or
pbs or npr
um and and again they're scrappy and
they have different standards and
they're run by younger people with less
experience and i say seriously i say it
with respect um
some of the stuff that has been
appearing that val has been kind of out
there spreading
really oversimplifies things there is
not
everyone who in business journalism
who's been focusing on deutsche bank and
donald trump has spent much of the past
probably five years certainly past four
years
searching for
proof of this elusive rumor
that deutsche bank it's not really
deutsche bank that's financially
supporting trump it's russia that is
financially supporting trump and there's
a tremendous amount of smoke there and
tons of circumstantial evidence and
everyone is looking for the fire and
me more than anyone and man i wish i
could stand here right now and say i
found it but i didn't and neither did
val and it neither did the news agent
news outlets that he's been talking to
there's a tremendous amount of
circumstantial evidence i think this
book provides the most comprehensive and
accurate description of what that
circumstantial evidence is and what it
means and how to interpret it but
if you're reading things like
that this russian uh this kremlin link
bank called vtb was secretly financing
trump loans that may be true and that's
the rumor we've all been chasing in the
media for many years now there's not
proof of it and val doesn't have proof
of it i wish i did have proof of it but
i don't
yep
hi i didn't get all the way through the
book yet either so i don't know but um
there is
there is a lot of news around donald
trump's tax returns and that the
deutsche bank has been subpoenaed to
produce them and you would imagine if
they've loaned him money they have a lot
of financial documents so what is your
take on whether they're going to produce
them whether they have them they've
implied they don't have them yeah this
is another weird one where my reporting
and my life has intersected oddly
and kind of serendipitously with the
news here so um
so first of all just as background uh
there are a couple of congressional
committees here um the house financial
services committee and the house
intelligence committee that are both
conducting investigations
of that involved deutsche bank and its
relationship with donald trump and
both of those committees have subpoenaed
deutsche bank this is i guess last
spring
seeking basically everything they have
on donald trump which includes and not
not only donald trump but his family and
his companies as well and so that
includes his tax returns it includes any
kind of financial statements they have
related to his businesses or himself it
includes any documentation by the loans
or other services they provided it
includes documentation about any
suspicious transactions that the bank
detected involving trump and kushner's
accounts
and so
one of the things as soon as i heard
about this i started talking to some of
my sources who had been
at the bank during the period when all
these trump loans were made
and a couple of my sources were actually
involved in deciding whether to make the
loans and in reviewing trump's financial
documents as part of the kind of due
diligence process and two of those
people
told me that not only did they have some
of trump's tax returns they had
uh it wasn't the full tax return it was
the first several pages of
god i can't even remember the form it is
it's been a long day but uh going back
from about 2011
to 2014 i think and not only did they
say they had them these people had seen
them so and they'd seen them in the
bank's possession
and then in a court hearing in federal
court at trump sued deutsche bank to
prevent it from complying with these
congressional subpoenas there's been all
this legal wrangling going on did he sue
them to return them to him no he sued
them to just block them from complying
and
uh so in a court hearing deutsche bank's
lawyers said you know what we do have
some tax returns but we don't have
president trump's personal tax returns
and this left me scratching my head
because i had talked to people who had
uh said they'd seen them and so i called
i actually texted uh one of these people
and i said you're not going to believe
what just happened in court
they said they don't have them and he
says
i mean i'm not even going to say it
because we've got cameras here but there
he he there are some uh obscene words he
used and he said they're lying i've seen
them with my own eyes i don't know if
they destroyed them or returned them or
what but they definitely had them so
i've done some more reporting and it
sounds like they gave them back
and i don't know
to trump and usually i don't know
exactly what happened in these
circumstances but usually what would
happen is that a client has the right to
request that his materials be returned i
don't know when that happened exactly i
mean it was certainly in the past couple
of years but it i don't know if that
predates or post dates i imagine it's
before these subpoenas were issued
because i don't think even
reckless criminal deutsche bank would do
that after they had received a federal
subpoena but i don't know um
anyway point being it sounds like they
do not have president trump's personal
tax returns they do have some of the tax
returns that were sought by these
subpoenas which includes his family
members or could include his family
members and his companies the tax
returns though i have always thought are
like i want to see them as much as
anyone the and the new york times has
kind of led
not because of me but because my
colleagues has led the way in reporting
on us on his taxes but to a certain
extent it's a little bit of a red
herring i think the tax returns are if
they ever become public are not going to
show some of the most important things
we want to know about trump's finances
they're not going to show his sources of
income they're not going to show his
business partners
uh they're not going to give a real view
of his of which assets he has that are
valuable especially in countries uh that
are outside the countries outside the
united states the things that deutsche
bank has that are much more valuable are
going to be
just his other financial statements his
income statements any documents around
and my understanding is the bank has
very detailed kind of like org charts
almost that show the relationship
between different trump businesses that
they have with each other where all the
money is coming from and going to
they've got the documents or a lot of
them and they've also got documents that
show
some of the concerns that employees
raised about suspicious transactions
that went on in the trump and kushner
accounts and this is something
that is not i don't think it's not
gotten as much attention as i would have
thought it would but and there are
employees in deutsche bank's offices
compliance officers who raised
repeatedly uh red flags about what they
deemed to be suspicious transactions
involving trump and kushner's accounts
including in the kushner case of money
going to russians
where uh and their concerns were
overruled and it was never reported to
the government and in one case the
employee was fired after speaking out
about it wasn't there some money to
russians while he was in his
inauguration or late stages
it was it was the kushners were the
kushner companies or in the summer of
2016. yeah which is
amazing
yeah and it's amazing to me
you know banks always struggle with
compliance issues and they struggle with
when and how to file what's known as
a suspicious activity report with the
government
most banks err on the side of
over-reporting these transactions rather
than under-reporting them and they
over-report them to such an extent that
it's actually a problem it's like they
flood the treasury department with these
reports to such an extent that you can't
make heads or tails of anything deutsche
bank
just inexplicably
decide to go in the opposite direction
which is holding back on these and in
particular even when someone a couple
fuel raised a fuss about these trump and
kushner transactions
they still didn't do it uh
so
is there still a chance the subpoena
will be
yeah yeah
they will yeah there is i mean there are
oral arguments before the supreme court
on march 31st and a decision expected in
june
and so it's entirely possible i think
that the court will order deutsche bank
to comply which would mean they'd be
handing over documents trump's financial
documents to congressional democrats
over the summer
and
the story continues
hi uh you mentioned that bill
brooks-smith was a banker with a
conscience can you give any examples of
when he
urged darchbank not to do something or
maybe when he persuaded them not to uh
yeah a certain course the um and this
isn't
entirely responsive to what you're
saying but the the clearest example of
his conscience i think or not even his
conscience his just good business sense
in being a conservative businessman
was that he was on the oversight board
of deutsche bank's main us legal entity
it's an entity called deutsche bank
trust company americas in case anyone
was wondering uh
and this is the legal entity that among
other things was doing the lending to
donald trump and this is an entity that
has at any given time tens of billions
of dollars of assets going through it
and it's an entity that is only a very
few employees including no chief
financial officer no real accounting
staff
and brokesman raised a huge stink
internally on the oversight board about
why it was that this hugely important uh
part of the bank that was under intense
scrutiny from our friends of the fed and
uh
why on earth they didn't have a cfo why
on earth were they they seem to be
shirking the uh
some of what the fed was asking them to
do including trying to conduct really
aggressive we're known as stress tests
in the banking industry and brokesmith
was one of the few people inside the
bank these emails showed that was really
pushing the bank to take more seriously
what the fed was asking
and to just really clean up its act and
he he did not succeed
hi looking forward to reading the book
um can you talk a little bit more about
uh justice kennedy's son and what role
he may have played in the approval of
trump's loans through deutsche bank
yes
um
everyone really is interested in in
justin kennedy um which is justice
kennedy's son so justin was at deutsche
bank from for about 10 years from i
think it was 98 or maybe 99 until 2009
and he was in the what was called the
commercial real estate business of the
investment bank so his job was to make
big commercial real estate loans like
finance the construction of high rises
and hotels and things like that and then
package those loans cut them up into
lots of pieces packaged them into bonds
which then got sold to investors and
kennedy's role
was to basically handle kind of the
second half of that process rather than
the first half of the process so he
wasn't the one going out and saying i
will lend to you and you and you he was
saying if we lend to you and you and you
this is how mechanically we will be able
to kind of package it into bonds and
sell it and
our expectation based on how we're going
to sell it and structure it affects how
much money we can afford to lend you and
the interest rates at which we'll make
this loan so it's actually it sounds
kind of technical and complicated but
it's actually in a lot of ways the most
important part of the lending process
and kennedy had a strong personal
relationship with president with donald
trump and ivanka trump as well and he
was one of the people who on a number of
loans most notably i think the they did
a huge 640 million dollar loan to trump
uh to build a huge skyscraper in chicago
and kennedy was one of the lead kind of
point men on that transaction and this
turned out to be a really fateful
uh loan for both trump and for deutsche
bank because it was made in 2005 and
three years later the financial crisis
happens and um
trump is having a lot of trouble selling
the luxury condos that are in this
building and so he asks he has to pay
back the money or he's supposed to pay
back the money and and he asks deutsche
bank for a six-month extension and they
grant it and the extension it comes up
in november of 2008 right as the
financial crisis hits and um
and trump doesn't have the money to
repay or doesn't have the desire to
repay and
he just he takes this very unorthodox
approach which is in addition to
defaulting on the loan he sues deutsche
bank arguing that because of the because
the financial crisis was an act of god
it essentially void voids the contract
and on top of that i'm going to sue you
because you caused the financial crisis
and i want three billion dollars in
damages and um
so that led to a bunch of litigation
and you know i've done a bunch of
reporting around kennedy's role in all
of this
and uh kennedy bumped into trump so
trump sues the bank the bank is like
you've got to be kidding me this is not
the first time he has done something
really aggressive with deutsche bank and
cost him a bunch of money and so finally
the bank is like we are done with this
guy once and for all seriously and
they're not by the way but uh
but they that was kind of the the
temporary thinking and that meant for
kennedy that his one of his important
clients was gone from the bank and he
kennedy bumped into trump a short while
after that lawsuit was filed and trump
said something to the effect of you know
no hard feelings i hope and kennedy and
kennedy you know thinking about his
long-term future uh
yeah no problem business is business
let's like be pal still and in fact he
was he left deutsche bank at the end of
2009 and went on to strike up a very
long-term and very successful and
lucrative business relationship with
trump and his children hel and the
kushners as well helping them do a bunch
of other projects even after he left
deutsche bank so
um
anyway i can't even remember exactly
what your question was but the the
relationship between trump and justin
kennedy was long and
and multifaceted anthony kennedy would
often come by deutsche bank's offices
and talk to kennedy and his uh his
colleagues and give people hugs so he
was a known presence in
the deutsche bank offices and i don't
want to spoil the ending of the book but
that book comes back to this at the end
uh beast kennedy obviously leaves the
supreme court and without giving
anything away i will say that's not
entirely unrelated to the work his son
had done at the bank many years earlier
excuse me
in other words you said that microfiber
microwave microphone
this is reminding me of a conversation i
had with my husband ten years ago or one
of trump's
sort of more high-profile bankruptcies
when i said that he and my husband and i
were worth more than donald trump was at
the time so
um i'm really interested in following up
a little bit on the conversation from
the federal reserve gentlemen here
what if any
action has the german banking regulators
or the european um banking regulators
taken against torture bank given
the recklessness you know not just in
this case with trump but i mean in the
rest of their business
um
the
american regulars who i spoke to for
this book
a number of them
described the german regulators in using
kind of similar phraseology which was
that they were the representatives of
deutsche bank and the the german the
main german bank regulator is an agency
called baffin which is known for i mean
it plays defense for its hometown
companies and deutsche bank is the
biggest hometown company there is it's a
proud national institution
and an american as americans launch
american agencies and british agencies
as well launch all sorts of criminal and
civil investigations into the bank they
would deutsche bank would insist that
those like inquiries for and request for
information didn't go straight to the
bank or the bank's lawyers they had to
be routed through
the local regulator which is kind of
technically the way it's supposed to
work but it's usually not really rigidly
enforced but deutsche bank would insist
all of these requests for information
would go through boffin and they would
just die in this maze of german
bureaucracy uh and this happened over
and over and over and over again
more recently i think boffin has kind of
gotten the message that they need to be
a little more serious and there is now a
new pan eurozone regulator that
ostensibly regulates deutsche bank um
but the us has been mu the us and the
british authorities have been much more
aggressive i will say to a friend of the
fed that the fed i don't think comes
across looking all that good in this
book either i mean they're a numb sorry
uh it's mostly your account your
colleagues in new york though uh the
um i mean the fed was aware of
and had an opportunity to stop
money laundering involving russians with
deutsche bank going back almost 15 years
now and on multiple occasions just took
this very soft kind of slap on the wrist
we'll like write you a written penalty
and you better not do it again
uh approach would just you know we now
know didn't work but even at the time
and there's a scene in the book where
uh deutsche bank gets their their
compliance people get kind of chewed out
by
uh fed officials who are angry at them
about laundering tens of millions of
dollars
for wealthy russians and they're
expecting based on the angry tone of
these regulators that they're going to
get a penalty somewhere in the range of
about 100 million dollars
and instead they get a penalty of zero
and they're just urged to please stop
doing it uh which has about the effect
that you would think it would
i can't can't resist the
open mic here i guess so
but my questions may be a little nerdy i
don't know it's more one of
clarification you mentioned that over
about 10 years or 20 years
that um
deutsche had
lended trump
and maybe the family more generally but
trump
uh
2 billion dollars and that somehow he's
been able to sort of whittle that debt
down to 350 million
um how much of the difference between
those two figures can you
sort of track in terms of profits from
the
businesses that were financed through
those loans profits for trump are
profits for deutsche bank
profits for trump
well in other words that he's the one
that has to pay back right so yeah i
don't think trump has i don't think the
loans haven't been really profitable for
him they've enabled him to do things
that are very profitable whether it's
and the loans with from deutsche bank
one of the remarkable things about them
is that deutsche bank was so desperate
to
do business with anyone it could
including trump it was practically
throwing money at him even after he
defaulted they were charging these
ridiculously low interest rates that
anyone any of us with clean credit
histories wouldn't in a million years
get like two percent on on a 100 million
dollar loan for example which is
i mean fabulous um and uh so that in a
sense is a hugely profitable transaction
for trump because even though he's
paying interest on the loan if he pays
it back it's still
much cheaper than he'd be able to get
anywhere else and it allows him to go
build things or buy things
that are going to
produce income at a rate much higher
than two percent and so
it's very easy to pay back what but
trump i mean the funny thing about this
is that trump despite his defaults and
despite his record of not paying anyone
back for the most part deutsche bank has
emerged out of this pretty hole and so
it's not as if deutsche bank lost
buckets of money on this relationship
with trump and it was first of all
charging him huge fees for all sorts of
other services they were providing
whether that was managing his money or
and again not to spoil stuff that's in
the book but
playing kind of matchmaking services for
him where it introduced him to wealthy
russians who wanted to invest in western
real estate including his resorts um
but it was the bank was uh
you know in the end in the final
accounting i think from a purely
financial perspective the relationship
with trump probably was profitable it's
destroyed their reputation but it's uh
just in terms of the pure dollars and
cents financial impact i think it's
probably been a good one yeah right but
the difference between the 2 billion 350
million yeah so that's just a product
that's unclear no it's the explanation
no it isn't clear yeah no it's pretty
clear so the those loans first of all
date back to 1990 the 2 billion dates
back it starts in 1998 with a loan to
gut renovate a building on wall street
and those loans got paid back over and
over and over again so the 350 million
are sim i think it's four loans maybe
five loans that have been made since
2011. the others have been paid back
either to deutsche bank or to other
parties that had ended up lending it
thanks yeah sorry that was a simple
question that i made very complicated
isn't there a lot of irony here that the
germans are supposed to be these prudent
savers
and uh
uh you know
i've always
felt this and all of a sudden deutsche
bank which is their national bank
is wanting
money this way to trump and
and others i mean
does this money come from those prudent
german savers that are that's being
alone well deutsche bank is most of the
money it's lending is actually money
that it's borrowed from big
international investors uh through
issuing debt or selling stock things
like that so it's not the german savers
who are subsidizing the trump lens but
the interesting the real irony of that
to me is that the whole reason deutsche
bank felt it was necessary and important
to get into
doing the wild and crazy stuff it did on
wall street and with characters like
trump is that it turns out that being
the bank to a bunch of savers and people
who don't really want to borrow money is
not lucrative and so the bank at that in
the 80s and 90s was watching as its
rivals in america and in london
were just
minting money on all sorts of crazy wall
street activities and on people's
just burning desire to get into debt
people in institutions burning desires
to get into debt and so
deutsche bank serving a primarily german
clientele
the germans did not want to go into debt
they had been you know they're scarred
by their own historical legacies and uh
and so deutsche bank went was really
trying to boost its profitability and
attract international investors and the
way to do that was to make money by
lending by getting other people more in
debt and so it turned its sights toward
uh really all over the world but um
including an america where it found
people like trump and can i just also
say before i forget this is completely
unrelated to your question but uh
it's not just trump that they were doing
business with and trump is obviously the
most famous kind of marquee client they
had and obviously it's generating lots
of headlines but i mean this is a bank
that was so desperate to get in bed with
anyone who could that it would just it
would it was really just open for
business with the worst of the worst of
american capitalism and jeffrey epstein
i think is the kind of clearest example
of that jeffrey epstein obviously kind
of lied to everyone and said he was a
billionaire and was this wonderful
financier blah blah blah and but by by
2012 2013 after he'd been convicted of
sex crimes people realized that he was
kind of full of it and that he was you
know morally reprehensible and so he
started getting kicked out of his banks
and the final bank to kick him out was
jp morgan which finally washed its hands
of epstein in at the end of 2012 early
2013 and epstein who at this point was
you know had a lot of money that he had
somehow from some people and was still
trying to keep up this facade of being
this international kind of businessman
didn't have anywhere to go and he
probably would have had to shut down his
dirty little operation were it not for a
certain bank that came and decided even
when every other bank had cut him off
from the financial system it was willing
to get in bed with him and that bank you
will not be surprised to hear was
deutsche bank and deutsche bank
continued to do business with epstein up
until the time of his arrest last summer
and that was even after
multiple employees in the compliance
division and elsewhere in the bank
raised concerns not only about the
ethics and morality of doing someone who
is not only a convicted sex criminal but
also was well known to be having done a
lot
more bad stuff than what he'd been
criminally charged with but it was also
that they were seeing signs internally
of him laundering money and possibly
bribery and things like that and yet the
bank
once again overruled those concerns and
continued doing business with epstein
because it seemed lucrative to do so
yeah this is a bad bank
yeah i was wondering uh you know first
what is sort of the net worth of
deutsche bank right now and then what is
the
roughly the total amount of fines and
settlements they've had to pay
associated with conduct related to the
financial crisis yeah uh the first
question i don't know off the top of my
head um
what i the metric i have in my head is
that it's stock peaked in 1990 or in
2007 it was at the time the world's
biggest bank
as of a couple of months ago its market
value had declined by 95
from that peak it actually has gone up a
little bit in the past couple of months
because
people inves some investors are i think
getting a little more confident that
maybe they are
going to focus on reforming themselves
uh
the
um
they've been fined i don't i don't know
the exact number in how much they've
been fined either is well over 10
billion dollars
which sounds like a ton and it is a ton
it actually probably is not the bank
that's received the biggest fines um
this is an industry that has
been fined a lot and uh has behaved very
badly and deutsche bank definitely has
the distinction i think of being the
world's most destructive bank and
i think that's in part just the pure
destruction of
money that it's and you look at that in
their market value declining by 95 which
is pretty impressive but they've also
basically every financial scandal over
the past 10 or 15 maybe 20 years
deutsche bank has been either at or near
the center of it whether it's laundering
money bribing government officials
manipulating interest rates manipulating
currencies
evading taxes violating sanctions
have i said laundering money laundering
money deceiving its customers ripping
off governments you know i can go on uh
it's a bad bank
clean house and get new management
recently um they've cleaned house and
had new management several times in the
past uh
10 years the guy who's running it now is
a guy named christian saving who has
been at deutsche bank for 30 years he
spent his whole life there um
i've met him he seems serious
and
the bank is
shrinking a lot and trying to turn over
a new leaf
uh and he kristen seven said uh
i think late last year as he announced
kind of the latest turnaround plan that
they pretend to investors that finally
we've made a ton of mistakes over the
past several decades we're going back to
our roots and we're going to be a lot
like the way we were back in the olden
days and i remember thinking when i read
that he maybe needs to brush up a little
bit on their history before he says
things like that um
so it's they have a long tough road
ahead and
it'll be interesting to see whether they
survive
so we have time for one more question
thank you very much i really been uh
enthralled by your information my
question to you is
it's obvious that deutsche bank played a
very integral role in getting donald
trump back on his feet financially as
you've alluded to and documenting your
book so brilliantly
but don jr
as we've seen so many times on
television when he was asked quite a few
years ago well how is it that your
father got back on his feet financially
if all the traditional banks kept
turning him down turning him down
and he so foolishly said oh
the russians we got our money from the
russians
so what fundamentally is the connection
between the russians
like probably vtr and deutsche bank
which you can't get a clear picture on
or handle on but there's obviously it
doesn't take a lot to connect the dots
between vtr
and deutsche bank it's vtb tv
it's actually the the the i think it was
eric trump who made the comment about
the russians financing the golf course
and it's even better than you said
because he said
donald trump or the russians have been
financing our golf courses and right at
the time that he said that they had just
bought a new golf resort down in miami
called the doral
and guess who paid for the financing of
that deutsche bank and so he said
publicly that it was the russians who
paid for it but it was actually deutsche
bank who paid for that paid for it and
so is obviously very confusing in eric
trump's mind whether it's the russians
or deutsche bank and uh
and
the
so look deutsche bank has been
uh in russia for on and off for more
than a century
it has
extraordinarily close ties with uh
russian companies and with the russian
government they're the bank's long-time
ceo and joe ackerman when he stepped
down as a ceo vladimir putin offered him
a job in the kremlin running the russian
sovereign wealth fund um
and vtb which is known as kind of the
spy bank because it was it because it
had offices all over the world it was
kind of an outpost for russian
intelligence and it financed uh the kgb
during the cold war and is now run by a
close pal of putin's and vtb the links
with deutsche bank are so close and the
the son of the ceo of vtb was running
deutsche bank's moscow operations for a
long while until he died in a mysterious
accident
vtb
and deutsche bank have
and basically the entire team that
started vtb's investment banking
business was a crew that was hired
directly from deutsche bank um
the two banks have lent each other tens
of millions of dollars uh in recent
years and it um it's not even tens of
millions
hundreds of millions of dollars they
have been lent and so the ties are very
tight and um
you know it's it offers a very neat
explanation for why
deutsche bank would be willing to take
such extraordinary and imprudent risks
on lending to trump maybe they weren't
taking any risks maybe those loans were
essentially guaranteed by vtb
which would mean in essence that it was
vtb
and therefore the kremlin that was
financing donald trump all these years
not deutsche bank that's that's the that
is the
delicious
entirely plausible
rumor and i and so many other
journalists have spent i mean i in
particular honestly because i've devoted
the past several years of my life to
digging into this like i've been looking
i've been examining documents i've been
interviewing
and
scores of people who are involved in
this
and
i don't know if it's true i don't have
proof what i have is a lot of
circumstantial evidence and there is a
lot of circumstantial evidence and
um
yeah i wish i could say more
what would be your speculation as to why
vtb
is so enthusiastic of financing
trump obviously in indirectly through
deutsche bank can i say one other thing
about vtb sorry i just forgot yeah uh
felix sater who i don't know if anyone
knows who felix say yeah we all know
felix sater is uh
felix sater not that he's reliable but
he says that when trump was planning to
build a trump tower in moscow he says
and satyr was involved in this he says
that it was vtb that was handling all
the travel arrangements for the trumps
getting visas things like that so the
connect again seder is not the most
reliable witness on these things but um
why would they be doing this i don't
know i mean it would essentially be the
kremlin doing it and we know
obviously that
the russian government was interfering
in the 2016 election trying to get trump
elected and so it's not that hard to
imagine
why a government-owned bank
would be trying to make donald trump's
life a little easier and make him kind
of a more
kind of
you know polish his record as a
businessman um but again like i do not
have proof that that is what happened i
don't even have it's not even proof it's
like
there are a lot of rumors there's a lot
of circumstantial evidence but it we
would never publish that in the
newspaper because we were just it's not
solid and i wish i had it but i don't
yeah be
strictly uh classified maybe speculation
at this point but i guess my fundamental
question to you is
what horse and the race do the russians
have
through uh vtb and directly through a
deutsche bank of supporting trump what
are they going to ultimately gain by it
what's their end game well look their
end game clear the russian government's
end game clearly was to get trump
elected maybe that wasn't even the end
game i mean that was one of their goals
clearly and that obviously was
successful
uh i don't i don't know that vtb
was actually doing anything to support
trump financially or otherwise so all i
know are these rumors and so i
definitely i don't want to speculate
about why
they might have wanted to do something
that i'm not even sure they did
i know that's frustrating and
unsatisfying but
appreciate your honor
we will now we will now have the signing
right up here at the table and if you
can fold up your chairs and leave them
against something sturdy that'd be great
book tv continues now on c-span 2
television for serious readers